[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de 7,8 lipdo de 26 minutes pour
revenir sur l'essentiel de l'actualité
de la semaine dans les yvelines
au sommaire de ce vendredi 29 novembre
le réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines consacre une
série de conférences au feq news la
première avait lieu jeudi soir et nous y
étions
le projet de réforme des retraites avec
sa mesure phare de système universel ne
passe pas auprès de certaines
professions
jeudi 5 décembre grève d'envergure est
annoncée nous avons nous aborderons le
sujet avec notre invité marie lebègue
député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines
les conclusions du grenelle des
violences conjugales une nouvelle
manifestation des agriculteurs et
l'ouverture de la 35e campagne des
restos du coeur
nous ferons le tour de l'actualité de la
semaine dans le département
[Musique]
le réseau des médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines anime une
série de conférences ateliers autour des
fêtes news de la défiance médiatique et
encore des réseaux sociaux
le premier rendez vous s'est tenue jeudi
soir à la médiathèque du canal avec pour
thème les fausses informations sur le
climat manon varaldo étaient sur place
l'effet que news qui signifie fausses
informations sont entrés dans notre
langage courant pour lutter contre la
désinformation une conférence était
organisée à la médiathèque du canal sur
le thème du climat
on n'a pas un journal
délaissant des chiffres qui sont
produits ou qui sont contestés par la
suite
donc ça nous a semblé intéressant pour
une médiathèque de traiter ces sujets là
pierre hippolyte senlis a animé cette
conférence et fait partie de
l'association fait coffre première
association de journalistes à s'engager
contre la désinformation de masse avec
trente journalistes ils se sont
regroupés suite aux attentats de charlie
hebdo mais on avait un peu tout les
toutes les théories complotistes ou de
désinformation un peu con qui sont
sortis donc ça est un peu violent et la
11 c on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire la défiance médiatique a été
abordé avec les 50 participants avec
tchernobyl l'incendié lui brille seul et
de rouen ils ont aiguisé leur esprit
critique
ils sont revenus également sur greta
tanberg la lanceuse d'alert le
journaliste à alerter le public sur
l'importance de vérifier les sources
un premier pas pour lutter contre la
désinformation ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé et que je ne connaissais pas
c'est la recherche inverse sur
d'une information on a une photo aux
pics au redoux gaulle en inverse et nous
dit cette photo elle date de talent
époque se rapprocher de l'essentiel
c'est le message du journaliste lors de
cette conférence
la prochaine aura lieu le jeudi 7
janvier à 19 heures à la médiathèque du
canal marie lebey qu'ils étaient avec
nous vos jours jours alors vous êtes
député de la 4e circonscription des
yvelines
également vice présidente de coupe lrm à
l'assemblée nationale et vous
accompagnera tout au long de cette
émission les technos on en parle
beaucoup il a même été décidé cette
semaine de créer un conseil de
déontologie journalistique et de
médiation avec pour principal objectif
de répondre à la défiance envers les
médias
il s'agira bien d'un organe
professionnels indépendants de l'état et
ce qu'il était nécessaire d'agir pour
sur cette question des fausses
informations
alors il ya eu des mesures législatives
qui ont été prises au début du
quinquennat
je crois qu'au delà de ce qu'on peut
faire en matière législative il ya un
vrai travail notamment salué moi j'en ai
un certain nombre dans ma
circonscription les écoles les collèges
les lycées qui s'engagent justement pour
apprendre aux élèves à repérer
défectueuse j'avais été à une conférence
sur l'occasion du grand débat sur
le climat dans un ellis et il est montré
une vidéo et ce qui m'a frappé en fait
c'est que quand il montre cette vidéo
aucun des élèves n'est capable de dire
si qu'il avait tourné si elles étaient
datées c'était un organisme officiel
c'était un des bulls images montés les
uns derrière les autres
et voilà on peut déplorer un petit peu
que aujourd'hui on est très connectée et
on n'est pas toujours capable de
vérifier la source de l'information
et puis on voit quelle profession
s'organise comme dans votre reportage
avec cette association de journalistes
mais on a aussi de plus en plus quand on
fait des émissions politiques et c'est
très bien des émissions de débat un peu
ce qui s'appelle le tchèque info ou
aussi quelqu'un donne une information
elle est vérifiée en instantané je crois
que c'est un peu partout ces outils
combiné en plus de ce qu'on peut faire
en matière législative qu'on n'arrivera
interpeller les gens sur la question
défectueuse et leur rappeler que quand
on prend une information il faut
absolument la regarder avec un oeil très
critique alors je te vois une
information qui peut avoir un avis très
critique et qui a qui peut avoir du mal
à lutter contre l'échec news
c'est ce projet de réforme des retraites
qu'on va aborder alors nous avons déjà
reçu dans le jt des aidants l'hebdo des
syndicats des députés pour en parler je
souhaitais avec vous faire un point
avant cette grève du 5 décembre qui
s'annonce très suivie principale mesure
la fin des régimes spéciaux pour un
système universel beaucoup d'autres
points restent encore ta ajuster la
concertation est d'ailleurs toujours en
cours elle devrait selon le premier
ministre edouard philippe s'achever aux
alentours du 9 ou 10 décembre mal le bec
pour cette réforme le gouvernement a
engagé beaucoup de travail les députés
la république en marche organise même
des débats sur le sujet toutes les
semaines par son en france pourquoi les
réticences continuent avec notamment
cette importante grève à venir alors il
ya des réticences qui sont parfaitement
le gym on part en fait de quel sera
votre avenir une fois que vous ne serez
plus salariés finalement quand vous vous
êtes quand vous travaillez quand vous
êtes un actif vous garantissez votre
niveau du puits ce que vous gagnez un
salaire qui vous permet de vivre quand
vous arrêtez de travailler que vous
devenez un retraité en fait c'est vous
avez acquis un certain nombre de droits
au cours de votre vie professionnelle
vous n'êtes plus vraiment maître de du
revenu de remplacement vous allez avoir
et donc c'est très inquiétant pour les
français puisque c'est en fait
finalement un système de confiance entre
les générations puisque en france on est
dans un système de répartition mais
aussi entre la régénération de personnes
retraitées et l'état donc c'est normal
ensuite c'est angoissant parce que
on prend on met en place une réforme de
très grande ampleur on pense pas le
système comme ça a été fait à deux ans
trois ans quatre ans c'est souvent ce
qu'on a vu que les réformes précédentes
on dit aux français il faut que vous
soyez capable de vous projeter sur une
réforme qui va vous années 50 60 70 ans
voyez que c'est quand même quelque chose
qui est assez difficile à penser après
je voudrais rassurer quand même les
français on a pris le temps de la
concertation
ça fait deux ans et demi qu'on on en
parle de cette réforme on a les piliers
le dur de la réforme on garde la
répartition on met en place un système
par points
on met on met la fin des régimes
spéciaux en place pour un système
universel on corrige un certain nombre
d' inégalités qui existent dans le
système et puis en fait aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça qu'on a la grève la
semaine prochaine
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur c'est pas
tellement de m le pilier commun c'est
comment est ce qu'on ramène tous les 40
de régime dans dans le régime universel
et ça c'est difficile parce que ça veut
dire aller voir chaque profession chacun
des 42 régime et leur dire bon comment
on fait pour que le contrat qui nous
liait évolué vers le régime universel
donc moi je déplore qu'est la grève les
5 parce que on annonce déjà une grève
avant même d'avoir fini des négociations
est de savoir si oui ou non on est on
est d'accord pour autant on a des
négociations qui vont bien on a eu des
rencontres avec le premier né ce qui
nous a dit il ya des points de
convergence ya des points de divergence
avec les syndicats mais il ya un chemin
on n'est que de le trouver et on va on
va y arriver ensuite on prend le temps
de la concertation va assez lentement
sur cette réforme parce que quand vous
faites une réforme d'aussi grande
ampleur il faut accepter de prendre le
temps et ensuite effectivement les
parlementaires avec notamment sous
l'égide de jean paul delevoye se sont
très organisés pour aller partout sur le
territoire
parler de cette réforme pourquoi il faut
en parler parce que il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes qui sont liées à cette
forme il ya beaucoup de technique comme
vous l'avait dit il ya aussi beaucoup de
gens qui ne connaissent pas le système
actuel est donc qui ont du mal à se
projeter sur le système de demain si
vous n'êtes déjà pas en maîtrise de ce
qu'est votre régime notre et donc on a
des parlementaires on a 40 à peu près
spécialisés sur ces thématiques qui
sillonne la france il ya 50 réunions
prévues
on a déjà la moitié qu'il a été honoré
et de toute façon le dispositif va
continuer jusqu'à ce que la réforme soit
adoptée
et qu'est ce qui sort de ces réunions
quels sont les points d'inquiétude et
sur quoi ils peuvent rassurer les epide
alors
ce qui fonctionne assez bien c'est
l'universalité du système parce que je
crois qu'aujourd'hui les français trouve
ça assez paradoxal que il y ait des
avantages qu'ils soient les à des
métiers ne sont pas liés à des individus
vous pouvez avoir 25 individus
une carrière qui est jalonnée
d'événements et qui fait que vous vous
allez acquérir des droits mais
aujourd'hui elles sont pas liées à ces
individus c'est lié au métier est donc
cet attachement à la fin des régimes
spéciaux non pas pour un régime moindre
mais pour un régime pour l'ensemble des
français beaucoup plus adaptée à votre
carrière professionnelle au fait que
vous commencez dans un métier mais vous
pouvez aussi terminé dans un autre et
hier j'avais une réunion publique de
massy reconstruction un exemple très
intéressant une femme elle a fait une
bonne partie de ces quarts
professionnelle dans le privé qu'elle
vient de basculer dans la fonction
publique et elle dit moi je suis
incapable de lire mon système de
retraite
est ce que c'est mais 25 meilleures
années est ce que c'est mais six
derniers mois comment est-ce qu'ils vont
calculer et donc ça l'universalité
c'est ce qui marche très bien le régime
par points aussi parce que finalement
c'est quelque chose qu'on a déjà mis en
place pour une partie des français
si vous êtes cadre rattaché à
l'agirc-arrco vous avez un régime par
points
et c'est géré par les partenaires
sociaux c'est bien géré il ya des
excédents les points difficiles
peut-être c'est pour un certain nombre
de professions je pense aux avocats je
pense aux professions libérales ou
effectivement on voit que pour l'instant
il ne se projette pas encore dans le
nouveau régime certains nous disent
qu'ils sont encore très attachés à
garder ce qui est paradoxal mais une
caisse autonome comme le cadet des
avocats il faut qu'on aille convaincre
du bien fondé de pourquoi il faut que
tout le monde soit dans le système
universel et donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est un peu un travail et vous faut
prendre les avocats presque les uns
derrière les autres pour leur expliquer
et puis je pense enfin que ces points
durs ils pourront être levé qu'une fois
qu'on aura commencé à avoir des accords
avec certaines professions ou ça résume
spéciaux parce que ça rassurera les
autres sur la logique et le bien fondé
de notre démarche
kenseth grande grève du 5 décembre pour
mieux vous accompagner pour cette grève
on fera une édition spéciale le 4
décembre
donc la veille pour la retrouver sur le
7-8 journal
on va changer de thématiques on m'a
parlé du grenelle des violences
conjugales
donc après trois mois le grenelle des
violences conjugales a pris fin lundi
pour la journée mondiale pour
l'élimination des violences faites aux
femmes
l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
rendre son bilan avant avec une
cinquantaine d'annonce parmi les
principes à l'ouverture de centres de
prise en charge pour les conjoints
violents
l'état va co financé à 50 % de sites
dans chaque région de france la
suspension de l'autorité parentale des
père violent la notion d'emprise sera
inscrite dans le code civil et pénal
offrir la possibilité aux médecins de
déroger au secret médical en cas de
danger de mort
enfin former les enseignants sur
l'égalité entre les filles et les
garçons elles seront soumises aux
députés à l'assemblée nationale
est ce que voulait défendre est alors
bien sûr il ya déjà une partie de ces
mesures législatives qui ont pu être
transcrit retranscrit dans la loi parce
que vous savez que mon collègue aurélien
pradié qui est celle ehlers et je vous
le dis parce que c'est pour montrer
aussi que le sujet fait extrêmement
consensus qui a déposé un projet de loi
à la mi-octobre à peu près et il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle une commission mixte
paritaire c'est à dire un accord entre
le sénat et l'assemblée nationale qui a
eu lieu cette semaine sur le texte avec
effectivement le bracelet anti
rapprochement donc opérationnel dès le
début de l'année prochaine
et puis la question de la torre des
ventes voilà c'était des mesures qui
étaient prises qui ont été prises avant
la fin du grenelle on a aussi beaucoup
travaillé avec la république en revanche
les députés de la majorité pour enrichir
ce texte le faire aboutir
et ça nous permet d'avoir des premiers à
mesure qu'ils vont rentrer en action
très rapidement et puis on a ce qui sort
des conclusions du grenelle et que et
que vous avez rappelé et donc il y aura
il ya eu un ou une autre proposition qui
a été déposée par deux de mes collègues
guillaume bouficha et puis bérengère
couillard est donc là ça complètera les
dispositifs et puis on a toute une série
de mesures réglementaires qui ne
nécessite pas de passer par la loi je
pense par exemple aux 39 19 le numéro
d'urgence disponibles 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 qui du coup sera enfin cédé
que c'est acté par par le ministère ça
rentrera en application ce matin j'étais
dans une association
justement pour faire un petit peu le
point sur ces mesures leur demandez leur
leur retour ils ont bien insisté sur la
transversalité des acteurs la nécessité
de créer des ponts entre les acteurs et
je crois que c'est ce qu'on va devoir
contrôler ce genre on va devoir être
vigilant de vérifier que entre la police
la justice les médecins les associations
qui parfois accompagne les patientes les
victimes pardon et les les avocats qui
aussi de leur fournissant un conseil
juridique que tout communique bien se
parle bien et qu'il n'y ait pas un
moment de femmes qui se retrouvent
seules isolées et sans solution alors
lundi nous recevions au plateau une
représentante yvelinoise du collectif
nous tout ce collectif à l'origine de la
grande marche contre les violences
sexistes et sexuelles qui a réuni 49 8
personnes à paris selon un organisme de
comptage indépendant je vous laisse
l'écouté aucun budget supplémentaire n'a
été débloqué et ce qui veut dire
qu'aucune action supplémentaire ne sera
fait voler quelques mesures pénales ou
autres juridictions sont intéressantes
bien sûr mais sans argent on s'y baigne
des associations ne pourront pas faire
grand chose de plus dans les
commissariats les gens sont débordés on
parle de 80 personnes supplémentaires
pour mieux accueillir les gens dans un
pays comme la france qui à presque 100
départements ça fait même pas une
personne par département c'est
insuffisant
et voilà on est très déçu au niveau du
budget parce qu'on voit bien qu'il n'ya
pas une vraie volonté de changer les
choses alors nous tout réclame un
milliard d'euros dans la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes un
chiffre préconisé dans un rapport publié
en novembre 2018 par cinq organismes ce
milliard le premier ministre edouard
philippe l'annoncé mais pour l'ensemble
des actions en matière d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes ce sont 360
millions qui seront dédiés
spécifiquement à la lutte contre les
violences
une somme sur laquelle s'est penchée la
commission des finances du sénat
il a remis un rapport consacré au budget
gouvernemental de 2020 il apporte des
précisions et montre que le montant
effectif est en réalité de 57,8 millions
il précise aussi que les crédits
affectés à la prévention diminué entre
2020 et 2019
est ce que le gouvernement fait
réellement des efforts ou se conforte de
ce qui était déjà présent il ya beaucoup
de choses qui soient de rage je connais
bien c'est cette discussion budgétaire
parce que je sais et notamment pour des
secteurs qui sont aussi engagés que la
question de
l'augmentation du budget c'est toujours
un point très dur et très sensible et
qu'on a toujours l'impression que l'état
est particulièrement son cette question
des violences faites aux femmes est
vraiment au coeur de l'agenda politique
j'ai toujours l'impression que l'état ne
met pas assez d'argent mais je voudrais
dire que au delà de cette question du
budget il ya un certain nombre de moyens
qui sont déplacés il ya aussi un certain
nombre de procédures qui doivent être
mis en place mange effet organisé par la
préfecture des yvelines et la première
journée il y avait trois journées
thématiques avoir j'en ai sur la
coordination des acteurs j'insiste un
peu sur ce point là parce que en fait il
ya dans les yvelines énormément
d'acteurs il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
associatifs et la faim en asie
à l'occasion de cette réunion ben en
fait on se connaît pas on se parle pas
on est on est pas forcément en ir et ça
il n'y a pas besoin de budget pour
corriger ça il ya la saison je vous ai
parlé ce matin ils nous ont dit ils ont
fait le test ils ont appelé 39 19
et puis ils se sont fait passer pour une
femme victime de violence dans les
yvelines et le 39 19 leur a dit obama
même si vous voulez avoir un
accompagnement faudra aller à bondy
bondi quand vous êtes si on prend
l'exemple aux mureaux beaucoup plus loin
les élites ça fait quand même beaucoup
de route pour des femmes qui sont
parfois isolées qui n'ont pas forcément
les moyens de ceux de se déplacer et
donc je crois que et donc il ya un
problème sur le référencement par
exemple les associations par le 39 19
est ce qu'elles sont toutes bien
identifiée est ce que l'on peut bien
orienter les femmes je crois qu'il ya ce
premier enjeu la de la coordination de
la transversalité et puis il ya aussi
des idées qui peuvent revenir du terrain
l'association avec qui c'est et ce matin
on dit pourquoi est ce que parce que la
personne dans votre reportage parlait
des commissariats de police qui sont en
danger
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait pas appel à
la police municipale notamment pour
accompagner les femmes à leur domicile
si elles ont dû le quitter pour les
récupérer des affaires pour récupérer
des plaintes éventuellement donc avant
qu'on parle uniquement de budget parce
que c'est une question qui est difficile
je ne nie pas cueillir n'y a pas besoin
de budget mais avant de la question du
budget il faut regarder ce qu'on peut
faire pour améliorer l'effectivité de
tous les acteurs vous pourriez mettre
beaucoup plus d'argent sur la police
nationale les dépôts de plainte
ça ferait tout le ca n empêche pas que
pour y aura toujours un engorgement il
pourrait y avoir toujours des femmes qui
sont réticents à aller porter plainte au
commissariat
bien sûr il faut et questions
budgétaires importantes il ya d'autres
moyens aussi de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
on
un projet de loi sur l'émancipation
économique des femmes justement qui
parfois sont en fait sous l'emprise
psychologique bien sûr physique de leur
mari mais aussi économiques donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont qui sont
faites et je crois que c'est cette
politique coordonnée on évaluera s'il ya
besoin de dotation et de crédits
supplémentaires on pourra toujours le
faire en 2011 parce que vous parliez de
la police justement il ya un an était
inaugurée au commissariat de guyancourt
une plateforme pour signaler les
violences 6 et sexuelle il en existe
seulement deux en france au rayon s'y
est rendu pour un premier bilan un an
après une conversation anonyme entre un
policier et une victime de violences
sexuelles sexistes ou conjugal depuis un
an 18 policiers se relaie 7 jours sur 7
au 3e étage du commissariat de
guyancourt
inauguré par plusieurs ministres cette
plateforme permet aux victimes de
pouvoir s'exprimer ou se confier plus de
5000 signalements ont été enregistrés
dont 35% ont été transmis aux services
territoriaux pour des dépôts de plainte
ou encore des prises de procès verbaux
nous avons des chat qui viennent
d'outre-mer mais également d'un peu
partout en france surtout sur des
grosses villes on peut quand même dire
que paris bordeaux lyon lille ont
beaucoup plus de deux contacts chat que
deux villes un peu plus petite au centre
de la france en moyenne un chat avec une
une victime c'est environ 54 minutes
c'est une moyenne
on a des tchats beaucoup plus longs qui
peuvent durer jusqu'à deux heures les
signalements concernent en premier les
violences sexuelles
viennent ensuite les violences
conjugales et les violences sexistes
tous ces policiers ont reçu une
formation spécifique et sont épaulés par
camille puni c'est la psychologue de
cette plateforme
elle et sa compagne quotidien il y en a
qui après ses pouvoirs durant un temps
ensuite parlé avec moi de certains de
chats qu'ils ont vu qu'ils ont que plus
les marques et que d'autres j'essaie de
rester au maximum disponible pour
pouvoir répondre à toutes leurs
questions
sachant que le but c'est qu'il soit
quand même autonome qui puisse répondre
même aux victimes moi je suis un peu le
filet de secours lorsque effectivement
sont en difficulté la plateforme ouverte
à toutes et tous pourrait être amené à
évoluer avec le recrutement de nouveaux
opérateurs ou l'élargissement du domaine
des infractions
autre exemple de dispositifs un bus
santé pour les femmes
il a été inauguré cette semaine c'est
une idée de l'institut des
hauts-de-seine à laquelle se sont
associées les départements des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine la région
ile-de-france et la ratp
il sillonne dès à présent les deux
départements pour rompre l'isolément des
femmes et leur proposer assistance
médicale et juridique gratuitement on
ferme désormais notre page consacrée à
la lutte contre les violences sexistes
et sexuelles on va s'intéresser aux
problématiques rencontrées par les
agriculteurs
mercredi les agriculteurs événements ont
répondu à l'appel à la manifestation de
la fédération nationale des syndicats
agricoles et des jeunes agriculteurs
ils ont pris le départ à bazens ville
pour retrouver leurs homologues d'autres
départements sur le périphérique
parisien
un millier de tracteurs au total a
bloqué la route toute la journée on
écoute l'un d'entre eux interrogés par
nicolas d'andré l'agriculture française
c'est une des premières puissances
économiques du pays et on tue cette
agriculture on tue cette économie on
alerte
demain aujourd'hui on est capable de
nourrir notre population demain on va
importer et on mangera du grand
n'importe quoi et ça c'est vraiment ça
me désole pour mes enfants pour mes
petits neveux pour mes voisins et pour
tous les français
alors une délégation a été reçue par le
ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume à 17h une longue réunion suite
à laquelle la fnsea a annoncé suspendre
le mouvement avec les jeunes
agriculteurs elle devrait rencontrer le
premier ministre edouard philippe le 3
décembre avec les tracteurs ont repris
le chemin des champs dans la soirée
marie lebey que les agriculteurs disent
se sentir abandonnés que faire pour les
soutenir alors il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont faits à pour les agriculteurs
depuis le début il ya vraiment un
dialogue suivi
moi j'ai voisins dans l'hémicycle est
aussi collègue jean baptiste moreau qui
député de la creuse qui avait lui-même
agriculteur qui accompagne beaucoup ce
sujet et donc ils ont ils ont vraiment
des gens compétents pour pour les
exploiter pour mettre en place on a voté
un projet de loi sur l'alimentation de
l'agriculture au début du mandat qui
vise justement à rétablir l'équilibré
des relations commerciales entre les
transformateurs la grande distribution
et les agriculteurs aujourd'hui
mg on est conscients les résultats
seront pas totalement satisfaisant les
dispositions prises dans la loi met
beaucoup de temps à à rentrer en vigueur
sur le terrain et donc à partir du 1er
décembre les négociations commerciales
vont démarrer pour justement fort c'est
un petit peu la main notamment de la
grande distribution de ce que j'ai des
collègues aussi qui travaille sur les
pratiques de la grande distribution pour
justement leur dire il faut respecter
les agriculteurs sont comme s'est dit
très justement le reportage on va tuer
l'agriculture française et on sera on
sera dans l'importation
on a une vraie lutte à mettre en place
contre la grille machine moi je suis
très choqué des méthodes d'associations
comme l214 qui rentre dans des élevages
c'est la violation de propriété privée
c'est absolument inadmissible on peut
alerter les français on peut doit
travailler sur les conditions et sur la
condition de bien-être animal ça c'est
absolument fondamental je crois qu'il
faut aussi respecter les agriculteurs
vous savez quand vous êtes éleveurs
quand vous êtes éleveurs laitiers par
exemple que vous travaillez sept jours
sur sept que vous lever à 5 heures du
matin pour faire la traite
vous n'êtes pas pour le mal être animal
vous aimez vos animaux sinon vous fait
pas ce métier là vu les sacrifices que
c'est donc je crois qu'il faut
absolument qu'on soit dans une lutte est
dans une position même juridique
extrêmement ferme que ceux qui rendent
dans les abattoirs ceux qui agressent
les agriculteurs quand ils font leur
métier soit condamné c'est je crois que
c'est très très important
il faut qu'on travaille des avantages
avec sur toutes les questions des
relations commerciales mais par contre
il ya un point on a aussi besoin que les
agriculteurs soient très proactif sur
sur leur situation on a je sais qu'ils
sont pas toujours
enfin certaines filières sont pour
d'autres rencontres mais par exemple les
traités commerciaux internationaux
quand le président de la république va
débloquer des quotas à l'export de pour
la viande bovine en chine il faut
absolument qu'on ait des fédérations qui
s'empare de ces sujets qui forme les
agriculteurs qui les accompagnent qui
les aident à exporter c'est fondamental
parce que au-delà du marché français il
faut qu'ils gardent à l'esprit qu'ils
ont d'autres débouchés l'agriculture
française c'est une agriculture de
qualité
cette agriculture de confiance et donc
aussi en dehors du marché national de
vraies opportunités pour eux qui
permettront aussi de retrouver un peu
d'oxygène alors on arrive à la fin de
cet entretien merci marie avec d'être
venu sur notre plateau je le rappelle
vous êtes député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines et vice
président de groupe lrm à l'assemblée
nationale mardi
les restos du coeur lancent l heure
trente cinquième campagne d'hiver une
mobilisation dans toute la france avec
73 bénévoles dans les yvelines les
entrepôts mme déjà rempli leur stock de
produits pour les redistribuer dans et
26 entre mathilde demi s'est rendu aux
clayes-sous-bois jacques commun sa
journée à 6h30 à l'entrepôt des restos
du coeur aux clayes-sous-bois depuis
douze ans il a les mêmes rituels
préparer les commandes les emballer et
les charger mais depuis quelque temps le
manque d'effectifs se fait de plus en
plus ressentir
les années passent si vous voulez hier
25 kg c'était rigolo
aujourd'hui 25 kg on arrive tous dans
les 70 ans passés dans 25 kg deviennent
très très lourd et on demande à
à chacun bon attention on fait attention
on fait attention à sif attention à ça
et on essaie d'aller de l'avant mais il
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui s'il nous manque
une personne
c'est un problème dans les yvelines 1200
bénévoles travaillent chaque jour dans
les 26 centres pour distribuer les
denrées alimentaires élu depuis
septembre le nouveau président
s'inquiète du peu d'intérêt que porte la
jeunesse pour l'association
on a de moins en moins de candidatures
hélas on a quand même un certain nombre
de bénévoles qui nous quitte pour des
raisons tout à fait normal c'est
plaisant et abandonné de temps qu'ils
aspirent à voir un petit peu à peu plus
de tranquillité
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le
problème dont souffrent avant tout les
restos du coeur et le réseau associative
c'est un manque de bénévoles
un appel à l'aide de l'association pour
combler le manque d'effectifs
malgré le besoin de bénévoles les
livraisons arriveront à temps à trappes
sincère bois d'arcy et tous les autres
centres des restos du coeur dans les
yvelines
un petit mot paris 2024 le président du
comité d'organisation de tony estanguet
a annoncé la liste des 500 premières
collectivités à avoir décroché le label
terre de jeux 2024 parmi elles 14 ans
était yvelinoise on retrouve notamment
saint quentin en yvelines guyancourt
plaisir et l'encours
poissy-saint-germain-en-laye est encore
croissy sur seine
ce label permettra aussi de devenir des
centres de préparation aux jeux ils
pourront également accueillir des
délégations pendant les jeux olympiques
et paralympiques sur les périodes de
compétition michael et demi d'euros
vient reviendra largement sur cette
information dans le prochain 7,8 sport
de lundi
et c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de nous avoir suivi on se quitte avec
des images de la boîte aux lettres du
père noël installé à montigny le
bretonneux plusieurs de vos communes les
met à votre disposition pour poster vos
listre vos listes de cadeaux retour de
la cuvette et locales dès lundi avec le
7-8 journal weekend sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]